this is the calling this is an episode
where we have core still in the swamp
with Toph and a lot of kids are coughing
it up topping it at it but right after
the Korra nation yeah yeah I spent all
week working on that one
well done uh so all the kids are going
there looking for Korra there they have
to work together as a team doesn't work
out so well area citizen at the door
both III love Tenzin and I'm like now
remember to work together as a team like
go find a core and I'm like you're
really trusting these three I mean I
guess they did it in the end but I would
have been like what the hell but I'll
get to that in a second so Korra has to
confront her Empire Strikes Back fears
in the Empire Strikes Back way I mean
it's kind of amazing well remember when
we tried to talk about that in the
original avatar dirty West at like Star
Wars
remember it's not like Star Wars oh is
that okay okay all right in the totally
original way that kind of is Yoda is
kind of Aswath bitch kind of is going
into an area to confront her fears
through illusions ish um that has
nothing to do with this big sci-fi epic
that mean we're just compared to doom
yeah
there you go dude remember that scene
and don't know cuz I don't remember a
fucking thing from doom because it's a
terrible film II was sad except for that
flight back at sea holy 100 you're had a
name the Baron Harkonnen
I just know it that's all that was his
middle name
all right baron
and okay we're doing really off-topic
I'm sorry yeah uh but what do you expect
when an episode connects so clearly to
dude
because the Oh buddy will be offended by
that for some reason now this is totally
Empire Strikes Back it's just
unbelievable how much in fire strikes
bagging is fine I don't care it's there
if you're gonna rip off something rip
off something good I stress to exes yeah
that's the best um and even down to tov
almost like yeah I mean she's small
she's green she is you know it doesn't
take any shit and I know my favorite
she's like go pick mushrooms and like
she's walking in like the second she
comes up to that place with a little
circle in the middle I was like powerful
this place is with the dark side I'm
like here's our mystic cave no yes it's
like exact um but she thought she masks
a mod and it's her own face oh so she
finally confronts her fears confronts
her her enemy learns from her enemies I
really like that wine you know it's not
be afraid of your enemies learn from
your enemies and uh figures out a way to
take the metal out of herself meets up
with the kids again and now she can go
back into the Avatar state and
everything is going to be hunky-dory I'm
sure it's gonna end the next episode
because it's just gonna be a swift
resolution I know um so I can say this I
could say watching this episode there
must have been about three or four times
where I just looked at the monitor and I
said really really but I didn't mind
because it was such an adorable episode
I really like following these kids was
precious yeah it's it's one of those
episodes where is like it's one of those
words just it's like it's like dealing
with real kids in your lives it's like
I'm kind of infuriated and yet it's just
so cute at the same time yeah cuz on the
one hand you know where a lot of this is
going that and yeah man no it's we know
and the kids are it's like they're kind
of annoying but at the same time it's
like oh they're just so cute the one
thing you were talking about like when
tense is like you have to work together
as a team and the boy is like
working together as TLW in this big now
huh no no okay if I was tensing me like
no no that Mouse tension that air befo
start taking off I would air pin the
backup nope now you listen here you
little brat
that sister is in charge listen to her
you want uni because this is gonna
totally derail if you don't listen work
as a freaking team or I would beat the
living snot fart out of you got it okay
there you go like my head so much fun I
have faith in universe everything
Rebecca yeah I mean I guess that's kind
of like they venting like that I can
figure is that you know have them
discover on their own anti that though
wait am i I have no faith I have faith
in the cosmic screenwriters that this
will somehow work to a resolution that
will not only be humorous but that
people will find cute but it's one of
those things where it's like okay it
feels just like a small thing but ii
know you're finding the avatar to
restore balance to a world that you want
to go to civil war and everything emmy
don't be like oh they learned a way it's
like no you grow up and word back yeah
we we need to find the avatar therefore
I'm sending the Marx Brothers like
that's pretty much what it was mostly
sisters but your three stooges the
Markus sisters yeah boxes if you know I
mean Jinora knows what she's doing for
the most part like but the public she
wasn't leaving I mean they why and the
other to like the boy in particular I
would been like you know what you can
stay here girls have fun like I was like
there's no way unless maybe he was like
oh shit then he stays here you know what
go hey I'm giving you a high admission
um I know you see obviously when you are
in charge of Awesomeness yes no way yeah
guy Fartman yes you know you're just
that way it shows sensors let us get
away with it then yes um I just think
it's one of those were even though like
you said they are knowing there is just
something still an Arab Lee likable
about them I can see someone very easily
not liking this episode like come on can
we get to the serious stuff again I know
like I can almost say scene for seeing
what's gonna happen in this episode like
the uncle
just like I like the actor I liked the
Empire Strikes Back stuff and the kids
can get grading but I still liked them
and for me the highlight was um iki
getting captured by the two um the
garden yeah those guards were adorable
those are adorable government and
literally just like through her own
charm just completely like the telling
thing is like they did it twice and the
second time they did the joke it's funny
where she pulls the arm out of the ropes
oh yeah tied her to the chair but the
first time it happened in the background
I just laughed because it was almost a
blinky and II miss it yeah but everyone
she like scratches her head or something
can sticks our arm back then I'm like
okay so this is the joke she's in no
real danger like these guys are just
idiots er yeah even the little throwaway
guards I'm sure we won't see you again
but it's like I kind of hope we do cuz I
kind of like just know it I mean it's
adorable to my handsome little man on
another matter and I like how it's their
food that the kids breath oh yeah so I
like that like the guys talking about
his plan like what to do Thea do you
realize you know that these kids you
know looking for the avatar that means
that their airbenders of the related to
Tenzin if we capture them we can send
them to you know general Zelda know
those great stuff maybe macaroon I know
it's like no no it's like that's nothing
try this macaroon I mean it was
something else what the hell was I mean
but they were so likeable um I thought
they were absolutely hilarious yeah I
know what it was it said seen an
American tail with fifl and the forget
the name of the cat played by Dom
DeLuise the dumb police K yeah the Dom
DeLuise get like a terrific tiger yeah
Levi Tigard at first you think for a
split second he's gonna be scary and
instead he's just like a cream puff and
then they end up being friends it's
pretty much of what it was until they're
knocked out and it's like sorry my
brother and sister knock you up ever
mackerel I yeah riddle like oh those
nice that's nice
um I think it's kind of needed to
because the past few episodes like
especially the first couple have been so
heavy
I mean it's life and this is still heavy
like the I actually really liked the
vision that Korra had with the enemies
like it was still kind of intense so it
was a nice breather
like okay we're gonna have a little
comedy again which is something the
original show heads yeah and I think the
stuff with um something that I liked
when they were with Korra I liked how uh
you know she meets the kid she knows the
medal has to come out of her and she
goes okay I'm ready
hey you know like she says she says like
she's emotionally set and focused and
everything and Toph says I like to
innate you do it
I cuz at first I thought wait a would
talk tell her you know to prepare to
save on time but that was like no
because if she said that she's like what
what are you talking about you know she
wouldn't be ready so by having that
throat on her and her just feel like
okay let's do it I think it showed even
more that she was confident yeah I got a
weird Facebook question so he's like
what do you think now that they've just
resolved this whole working through your
issues arc and four episodes and I'm
like I shot his forehead so yeah I was
like that's a why I'm like we devoted
four episodes in a row from the
beginning of this done like I'm fine
like honestly if they did this at the
beginning of season 2 or any of the
other ones like I would have been fine I
don't need the whole season to deal with
it but just something that deals with
like the consequences and I mean and we
don't know if it's over nut she may
still like have to get I don't know but
she's got the avatar you know it's been
a trying to be past she's I'm gonna have
to figure out what to do with kuvira
know yeah I mean that's still got
Emperor's got em for general Zelda um I
do love it when they had the picture of
her hung up like a banner oh this is
only looking better and better um but
the yeah I think I was originally
thinking like what if they made it go
longer that be more build up for her
meeting up with general Zelda like and
the the fight would have been even more
built up as Kali I know words go we kind
of knew where I was going confront your
no years you know address your issues
and you'll be better use remember and
return the Jedi Luke goes back in Return
of the Jedi and you notice like you're
done
was it wait a second but you know what
that's a big it's like or you could
spend like an hour's worth of fraternity
the Jedi now with more of the training
jeans like at some point you can move it
along
yeah I mean I did I was fine especially
I said I knew what was coming the one
part I I said before they touched upon
I love liked a little bit more was it
was just a line but I thought man he
could've dealt even more with that was
the idea of not being afraid here any
but learning from your enemies I really
like that line you know cuz she does
think Bank and she just associate sin
with fear and she say won't you were
from why did you discover what made you
stronger and what you discovered from
that fear is the mind killer I brought
it back to dune they're nice just to
mess with your head
very nice that's clearly Empire Strikes
Back I don't know what you were quoting
there but this I would have been show
it's not referencing at all the mind
killer fear is it's the fight to the
dark side fear leads to anger anger
leads to hate hate these two around the
avatar and the bear perimeter 3hp oh
yeah what else is there to talk about in
this episode I'm traffic I mean it it
did seem kind of I though I have the one
thing we're talking about when we were
saying like how the kids I want to say
what idea there were some what are we
good lines to but I'm Mary did there was
a couple funny lines I remember laughing
really hard and I forget what they were
now but but they okay like the boy you
know it can be pretty annoying but it's
like he just walks that fine line of
you're almost annoying but you're just
funny and charming enough I think a good
age enjoy banished ladies into shape but
did the see what I really like when he
confronts not confront like he talks to
the girl there I forget he's asking for
directions or you know a little moment
he was a girl and I really like cuz he
suddenly gradually subtly like exposed
and so I don't and it's like it's your
girl
I had in my life for a life yeah it's a
genuinely cute moment I love if I think
it's a good artist
Oh that he draws for like amazing yeah
Devin awesome eMeter there's many things
you don't know about me also cuddly crap
I'm also a serial killer no it's those
little touches I think make this episode
just likable enough I think I try I
think did I forget her name the one that
got the tattoo G or Jinora did she ever
do any kind of leadership ish stuff at
any point that was the one thing where I
was sort of like looking she's gonna
come around and lead a little bit but
she didn't she ever dish never really
did she didn't kill the other two and I
think that's progress I think really
when it's all said and done like they're
gonna go home and Tenzin's give away you
know what you didn't kill your younger
sister brother good job Mike
I suppose I could just me walk to the
actual leading um no she did they did
say at the end it's okay I did this and
I did that and I said score I at the
last second so yeah that's again kind of
luck but you know ed pickers and juicers
whatever um and I wonder why they didn't
say she was the leader but it's like
they did you know and they just said you
all have to work together that's fine
but it's like they say you are the
leader then we couldn't have had a meal
Oh puking Berry's joke okay that was
kind of amusing how's your thing it's
like I've ever seen other kids show
vomiting in anything i watch anime so I
see now they don't like it okay show
that in an American kitchen American
kids shown that so much okay you didn't
see him vomit you saw the Nova lying
you saw the Lemur the weaned Rob advice
no I think if I've ever seen that I
think the closest I've seen is like
maybe there is a witch ever called
unknowing gravity falls that puked of
Rainbow they also found the clothes as
I've ever seen
um but yeah I couldn't think of any
other and I mean probably nothing to
think too hard about uh so yeah I mean I
liked it I can see how someone can not
like and see is kind of like a rushed
you know predictable episode but I think
the characters are likable enough I
think they're cute I think they're funny
and I think
there's a big try more than we've gotten
in three seasons like trying to deal
with the after-effects oh I'm I'm good
yeah no I like a lie solid I like the
animation for how the metal comes out -
I thought that was nicely done - for
exhibit very nicely done um so yeah see
you in children - I fear is the mind
killer